who is it come on I got to delivery it's
kind of hot out here buddy he's a
comedian his name is uh Michael David
ramport unprecedented access with
birdzilla better known as the Birdman
Chris Anderson it's Championship night
let's cut this back to you
guys have you heard of him uh I'm not
sure I'm really bad with
names let me tell you something if
you're into
a sex store sex stores or anything
lgbtq do not go to Gaza and in the
church that I used to go to the pastor
gave a sermon about why we have to
support Israel and then they uncover
this CBS News investigation has
uncovered a loophole that allows accused
and convicted American pedophiles to
escape Justice by moving to Israel show
me what Christians have done to Jews in
the last thousand years and show me what
Muslims have done to Jews in the last
thousand years and you will we know
there are many benefits to the use of
black black seed according to the
authentic statements of the Prophet
Muhammad peace and blessings be upon
them that's why I use the black seed by
tasim and 50% of the profits from your
order will go towards establishing the
dean Center the Masjid and mega dawa
Center use promo code the dean show for
15% off asalam welcome to the dean show
how you guys doing welcome welcome I
have a exciting guest here he was with
me online now he's in the studio
the I love you man you're do when I was
ready to talk about it I would only talk
to I was explaining how much respect I
have for the
of to
the
the I'm very excited to have uh Imam Tom
how are you I'm good alhamdulillah A
little tired short on sleep like
everybody but it's been a good stay in
Chicago I was here for the mass
conference my first real time in in
Chicago and I had a good experience so
alhamdulillah alhamdulillah so um we
have a lot to talk about um this next
clip I wanted to unpackage it because uh
before this this whole um what kind of
um steered Us in talking to against the
oppression that's happening in in
Palestine uh we were actually I was
talking a lot about um and and we were
aligning with a lot of the conservatives
and others who were seeing the um the
infiltration of the schools with much of
the sexualization of the children the
alphabet movement and uh yeah can you
imagine that was just like three four
months ago right you remember that that
was the main thing going on yeah uh so
there's this famous
actor who is it come on I got to
delivery it's kind of hot out here buddy
come on
Sparky what's up nice house he's a
comedian his name is uh Michael David
ramport unprecedented axis with
birdzilla better known as the Birdman
Chris Anderson it's Championship Night
let's cut this let's go back to you
guys have you heard of him uh I'm not
sure I'm really bad with names I see his
face okay does he ring a bell yeah yeah
yeah
yeah you know this whole crap with this
cancel culture and the shut up so we're
going to touch upon this topic cuz in
his video he brings it up but then he
also brings up Gaza interesting so I
want to get you reaction to this very
interesting uh again he's an actor
comedian and he's been very
outspoken I'm here in front of the
infamous Mash sex store right there
right here in Tel Aviv let me tell you
something if you're into
a sex store sex stores or anything
lgbtq do not go to Gaza this doesn't
exist in Gaza this does not exist in
Gaza it doesn't exist in the West Bank
okay does not exist in in Gaza you go to
[__]
Gaza and you start talking that [__] you
say where's the uh the lgbtq M they toss
you up for fuing building your thoughts
so is that is he being serious or is he
being factious or what's his sort of
like thing with that cuz I mean like is
he joking or yeah I mean it seems like
he's serious but is he really I mean
because the thing is and this is why
it's interesting and important to notice
how these these different ideologies
uh come together and uh there's another
related thing and I'm glad that you
brought up this this particular issue
because to me the lgbtq issue in the
United States and the Zionist issue in
the United States are very similar they
have Eerie similarities how why there's
two ways one that's relevant to that
video and one that's not mentioned but
needs to be mentioned the one that's not
mentioned in that video is
that the instit tions that we have have
been completely sort of hijacked top
down so if you there's a disconnect
between what the American people want
and what the government is doing okay so
if you look at for example when they
were rolling they were pushing through
all these sexualization of curriculum
and teaching you know gender fluidity
and elementary schools and things like
that bringing in very very you know
pornographic books and stuff like that
the average American is against this but
the lobby
the movement that was for this they
maneuvered in such a way so that they
basically were doing whatever they could
do until someone told them that they had
to stop and so you see that they're they
have powerful friends and Powerful
positions that know how to pull the
leavers and pull the strings and then
you saw the change on the ground the
same exact thing happens with Zionism in
the United States you've got politicians
we've seen in the last month or two two
Michigan uh Congress people were
approached by Israeli tied lobbies with
an offer of $20
million to stop their race that they
were going to enter into and run against
Rashid that's not any sort of
endorsement for her but we're just
saying that this is something that there
are politicians in the United States of
America that are under foreign influence
they are in the pocket of a foreign
government and the average American
would be against this the average
American is against this how are we
allowing this to happen so I see a
parallel a really interesting and
important parallel that the United
States government is not sufficiently in
tune with the American people what they
want the American government has been
captured by special interests in one
case the lgbtq lobby now we're seeing
also with the Israeli Lobby and if
people don't put a stop to it then
they're actually going to criminalize uh
Americans for for being against this
sort of stuff they're going to
criminalize Americans for if you're
against lgbtq by saying this is hate
speech and this is violence against
lgbtq people which is ridiculous um
which is sort of the conflation that he
makes in the video and then also now
they're going to say if you're against
Zionism if you're against the state of
Israel you don't stand with Israel then
you're a terrorist or you're a terrorist
supporter so they're trying to
criminalize us both ways and the average
American person they are smart enough to
realize that we're not for the
sexualization of young children and
we're against sort of the impositions of
the lgbtq m and we're also against our
government basically following the
interests of any foreign nation in this
case it's Israel but if it were any
foreign Nation if it were Saudi Arabia
if it were Sudan if it were any foreign
Nation it would still be a problem
that's issue number one issue number two
what he's saying is that one of the
things that zionists are trying to use
is the
dehumanization and the vilification of
Muslims and Arabs and Palestinians and
aans in particular in order to justify
their Slaughter right so the the person
and this is crazy because the person who
is an IDF soldier who gets in front of
the camera and is asked about and brags
about killing
babies or says how many of you killed
today only two or two it was a good day
which we've seen clips of people
actually saying this this is met with
nothing with no reaction
whatsoever and the possibility not the
reality but the possibility the
imagination that somebody who's lgbtq or
whatever is going to be harmed in Gaza
it hasn't happened the possibility or
the suggestion that it might happen
justifies killing 20,000 30,000 people
tell me how that math makes sense right
so there's a deep profound hypocrisy
that's going on and a lot of people like
I said the biggest thing I think in in
right now this moment for Muslims in the
United
States they are going to attempt to
criminalize us they are going to attempt
to come after us to uh intimidate us to
bully us to scare us just like they've
done in the past with you know other
people it's the new McCarthyism to try
to say that you're a terrorist supporter
you support this you support Hamas
whatever no we
don't we just want fairness we just want
the American government to be
responsible to the American people the
majority of American people are against
what Israel is doing but the government
is in the pocket of a foreign nation and
their influencers and their money and
their lobbies and their coordination and
it makes every single one of us who has
a conscience sick because that's my tax
money that's your tax money that's going
to all these weapons and bullets that
end up in the skulls of babies mhm right
so yeah I hope I uh I answered your
question but but it's it's really really
an important moment what I what I was
thinking because um he's
Jewish so you can you can still be um so
obviously he's ethnically Jewish but he
can't make the claim that God gave him
the land if we go to that argument
because he's obviously supporting
something that even his if he's a
practicing Jew right uh this is against
the Bible this is against the first five
books so what they consider that ship
was sailed long ago right Herzel and the
the founders of the Zionist movement
were most of them were atheists they
were atheists so they believe that God
promised them the land but they don't
believe in God uhhuh so how does that
square yeah that was ilhan pape I think
it was uh he's a Israeli Jewish
historian he he also brings this up that
it's ironic that now they're atheists uh
herzo and the rest of the founders but
uh they want to go ahead and capitalize
off uh uh God giving them the land but
they don't believe in God yeah of course
no that's why why they rely upon
demonization and vilification of Muslims
and Arabs they have to make us and the
people of Palestine seem like they're
animals bloodthirsty violent all the to
the end of it to justify what they're
doing I've seen some reports also where
they have um they've had people who have
been convicted of pedophilia and then
fleeing and capitalizing on the right of
return and getting caught up have you
heard of this I have heard of that as
well yeah yeah no and it it just it just
doesn't make I haven't verified all that
stuff and gone into it deep but I'll
play the I'm going to play the uh I'll
play the clip first of all I'm very sad
to say but Israel is a country which has
a pandemic of sexual violence people get
to see it where the the report where you
have H reporters and then they uncover
this CBS News investigation has
uncovered a loophole that allows accused
and convicted American pedophiles to
escape Justice by moving to Israel so
Ian Lee has been following this for more
than a year and he traveled to Israel
for this investigation yeah ju just the
fact even like even without that just
the fact that someone from Long
Island can get hop in a plane and go to
Tel Aviv and a get citizenship and an
AR-15 and military training and and
someone give them their house you are
stealing my house and if I don't steal
it someone else is going to steal it
like what world is this what world is
this and then and then he can kill
babies and then come back and resume his
normal life in the United States mhm
like again and this would be I would
have this position if this was any other
country this is not about Jewish or
Muslim this is not about whatever this
should not exist for anybody is our
slogan can we say I mean um what Islam
teaches us that all human life is
precious yeah of course of course and
even the purpose of warfare because
every society believes in Warfare the
purpose of warfare is to establish a
just peace yeah right so that's you know
if if you know everybody understands the
need to justify Warfare if not then they
wouldn't lie about these sorts of things
they wouldn't lie about Weapons of Mass
destru destuction for Iraq they wouldn't
lie about uh you know uh the need to
intervene you know in or or Israel or
the IDF wouldn't say that oh there's
Hamas in this Hospital there's Hamas in
the here there's Hamas in here they
wouldn't feel the need to justify it if
there wasn't an implicit understanding
that you need to justify violence
everybody agrees how do you justify
violence what violence is Justified
Islam teaches that Warfare has to be for
justice and just peace it's only because
there are people in this world that are
going to trample upon the rights of
others and commit oppression and
horrible things if they're not stopped
and anybody who's a student of American
History the American Revolution and
everything you know like they they
understand that so would you be somebody
who was um because that's something I
mean um even if you look at I think it
was Harvard University they have a a um
verse from the Quran right isn't it
about Justice yeah I believe so I don't
know top of my head yeah and uh so being
someone who's upon Justice would you be
as an Imam a community leader if this
was the roles were reversed right now
and you had what is it I think it's
203,000 innocent human beings right now
that's yeah of course listen when if
these were in The Other Side these were
Jews would you be out there to stop this
when when Isis was having its thing
everybody was against Isis and we were
talking about how unlam Isis was yeah
right that this is a travesty and an
Abomination and a and a rejectionism of
and there's it's ironic because Israel
has attempted to portray Hamas Isis but
the IDF resembles Isis more than than
the other side we were against this type
of behavior whether it's being committed
by Muslims or it's being committed by
Jews or by secularists or by atheists or
by Christians this is against our our
faith and so it's not and that's that's
something that a lot of people don't
understand is that we're not we're not
just being partial here it's not just
because our own people quote unquote are
you know in in the crosshairs this is
something that is wrong period it's a
moral wrong and Islam teaches that you
have to have the same standards for
everybody that you have to actually be
fair you can't just have principles now
it's all it was all about democracy and
and freedom fighting for Ukraine and now
with Palestine it's the complete
opposite right right that's that means
that shows me that you're a hypocrite
you don't have principles that you you
believe in your principles when it's
convenient for you when it suits you and
then when it doesn't suit you your
principles go out the window I believe
in principle if you're going to support
Ukraine if you're going to say that the
Russian aggression against Ukraine is
wrong then you also have to condemn
Israel and the aggression against
Palestine it's there there are very
similar things many people have drawn
the comparison between between Bosnia
between Bosnia in the 90s and and
Palestine if you're going to condemn one
you have to condemn the other right
don't be the type of person that you
know your sympathy and your Justice only
extends to history right it's like we're
going through something right now now
now is the time where people have to
take a stand and they have to be brave
because they're going to attempt to
paint you as a criminal or a terrorist
supporter or sympathize or something
like that which is not true but you have
to stand up and you have to say this is
not right I want my government to stop
it I don't support it and it has to end
I I'm I've been showing this clip to uh
many of my guests um and this is
something we touched upon in our last
program but this is the narrative that's
being pushed and you'll see what I'm
talking about in this next clip and this
is by former um Congress person woman
and also a dean of a Christian
University so I want to get your uh
feedback because this is really fueling
um The Narrative that they're trying to
create we can no longer Embrace this
being Mr Nice Guy to the people who are
in Gaza because this is over a thousand
years of mothers teaching their children
grow up and kill Jews grow up and kill
Jews it's the mind every accusation is a
confession that's all you have to say
and that's one of the most uh efficient
phrases that we've gotten out of the
last three months every accusation is a
confession have you heard this from yeah
I saw you seen this yeah yeah so I mean
this is recent yeah yeah this is they
had a big convention and you have a lot
of conservatives Christians com in and
now imagine thousands of people are
there not just at the the uh Hall but
also at the event but also now going out
in the media and people are hearing this
yeah of course it's just like Joe Biden
getting up and saying that babies were
beheaded and stuff like that you know
once you spread the lie and then what do
you right you have somebody in our your
own Community here in Chicago a
six-year-old boy that got stabbed off
lies the bunk yeah off of lies that that
the damage already done right so I mean
again like this they rely upon the
vilification and the dehumanization of
Muslims and Palestinians and Arabs in
order to justify the violence but what
we've seen is what's in their
imagination how do they come up with
these lies they take the things that
they're doing and they say that this is
what Palestinians are doing that this is
what Muslims are doing go there's so
much evidence online these days compared
to 20 years ago you can go online you
can see videos of the yeshivas right and
the the the schools in Israel and what
they teach the kids and they' have asked
them Point Blank like what does this
make you want to do it makes us want to
kill Arabs that's what they say right so
every accusation is a confession like
you know the Israeli state from the
Constitution from 1948 from its
Inception has been a racist State it's
been an ethnos supremacist State it's
been an apartheid state hate is built
into it hate is built into the the the
entire National project of Israel right
and they need to project that hate onto
Muslims onto Palestinians in order to in
order to keep on doing what they're
doing and to try to excuse their own um
Butchery now if that was I mean that's
coming from you now uh a Muslim Imam you
weren always Muslim you come from a
Christian background yeah I I just want
to um go ahead and let the audience see
this is a clip this is actually from a
former Zionist he was in the Special
Forces Israeli Special Forces IDF his
father was Israeli General and his F
great grandfather was somebody who
helped uh to start the state of Israel
and this goes with what you're saying
coming from from him Zionism is a racist
ideology the state of Israel is founded
on a racist
[Applause]
ideology Israel is an aparti racist
violent regime that has taken over
Palestine that is
how we need to talk about it I didn't
learn about Zionism in a college course
I didn't learn about Zionism from a book
my grandfather signed these Declaration
of Independence I grew up in Zionism I
know what Zionism
is and I reject it
completely you have to reject Zionism if
you have a conscience to be proud of
being a
Zionist what else is he proud of being a
pedophile I mean what is next very
important clip and that's this is one of
the things it's like for any rational
critical thinking person you have so
many people that are defectors from the
IDF from Israel Jewish people you Jewish
choice for peace you have other groups
of Jewish people that say not in my name
right it's like you can't use
anti-Semitism to cover the crimes that
Israel is doing Jews are saying this
right you have Jews saying that this is
entirely you know it's hijacking our
religion it's hijacking everything it's
completely unjust
M what do you see do you see these sort
of similar defectors from Palestinians
do you see how many Palestinians do you
see come out and say that yeah we were
taught hate from day one and only the
one or two that they've paid a lot of
money to like the one guy I can't
remember his name who's uh you know but
you know look at the proportionality
look at the wave upon wave of
conscientious Jewish people and and
conscientious people who have experience
in the IDF who testify against its
crimes against its racism against its
its every it's it's oppression and you'd
be very hardpressed to find any sort of
equivalent when it comes to the to the
other side how does that um how does
that lay with you when you hear Michelle
bachan when she's talking about for over
a thousand years so she's dating it back
before because this is relatively
something new 100 years right uh so now
she's talking about for over a thousand
years they're teaching so that means
that you also she's talking about
Muslims basically hating Jews you took
you you obviously took a deep dive you
know you you didn't it's not the popular
thing to go ahead and just become a
Muslim so you coming from a background
that she's she you're former Christian
correct yeah very intelligent you know
you really looked at the evidence did
you see any hint to that no absolutely
not absolutely not in fact the opposite
you know like and everybody in in
Palestine who actually remembers the
time before 1948 understands this as
well there's even Jewish people I saw
one video where there was a a Jewish
lady she was approached like in a
hospital bed and they were as she was
like very very old ' 80s 90s and we're
asking to describe what it was like
before 1948 what was relationship
between the the Jews and the Muslims and
she said everybody got along uh I I met
everybody got along everybody got along
and I met with uh with with wild halak
you know a professor at Columbia
University who's a Palestinian Christian
from a Palestinian Christian family and
he said the same thing he said it was
like growing up he said we had no there
was nothing there was no sort of
animosity there was everybody everybody
got along right so this is an invention
this is another invention that it that
you know Zionism has come up with in
order to justify its Slaughter that they
teach hate they've always hated us they
are an existential threat right it's the
whole thing with with weapons of mass
destruction you know this is a
preeminent strike or preemptive strike
rather right that we have to to you know
take away and and uh kick them off of
the land or else they're going to come
and they want to kill every single one
of us which is why they also go nuts
with the from The River To The Sea
Palestine will be free don't say that
now because they think that they can
only think within their imagination
again every accusation is a confession
they can if in their understanding in
the Zionist understanding what would
that mean that would mean wiping out
everybody and erasing everybody but
obviously doesn't mean that when
Palestinians and Muslims say that we
mean we want freedom for everybody
everybody who exists yes everybody Jew
Christian Muslim everybody who's in
between the Jordan River and and uh and
the Mediterranean Sea we want Liberation
for everybody but Liberation does not
look like Zionism free from a partti
yeah free from a partti free from a
racist State free from Zionism Zionism
is bad for Jews too Zionism is bad for
Jews it's bad for Christians and it's
bad for Muslims it's bad for everybody
it's only good good for the few people
who believe in the project and who are
sort of trying to you know now you've
got them systematically robbing houses
Ina as they sort of destroy them and
things like that it's only good for the
elite and the people who have put all of
their sort of selfworth into this
criminal ideology but it's bad for Jews
it's bad for Muslims and it's bad for
Christians so when we say liberate
Palestine from the rivers of the sea we
mean liberate Palestine and the Jews and
the Christians and the Muslims from
Zionism is it fair assessment if if
you're somebody who's supporting this
because we're saying on one end here
that all human life is precious uh we're
saying now that um we are on the side of
Justice truth and if somebody you have
the if somebody who's supporting this is
it safe to say that because a lot of
mkks are coming off we're getting to see
really like kind of what's in people's
hearts um and when you see that human
rights organizations Amnesty
International even Israeli human rights
organizations they've labeled this a a
partti yeah so nobody would be on the
side of a part South Africa but when
Jimmy Carter Nelson Mandela now they
have at one time he was considered a
terrorist and now they have his statue
in the UK is it right that's interesting
uh so now you want to be on the right
side of History so you have a lot of
rabbis Jews coming forward uh saying not
in our
name uh and if somebody's insisting and
and they'll insist and and they'll still
be with this even though the evidence is
overwhelming you know you have the
international uh un and organization
saying this is uh the these are an
oppressed PE this is what is it occupied
lands okay so my question is now can you
really question is somebody really who
supports this uh and then I had a just
one more point I had a rabbi who I just
interviewed Rabbi David and he relates a
an amazing story so he's he's 19 years
old he's like been sold this Disney uh
dream like of of Israel and he goes
there and what really kicked it off for
him was that he saw this young boy he
was hurt he was uh bleeding from his
hand so he took him to the proper
authorities there he's like get him some
help and he's he's flu in Hebrew so he's
telling him Hebrew like let's help this
boy and and then the um the soldiers the
police they looked at him said get this
Arab out of here so I was like imagine
someone said get this n-word out of here
right right yeah so that's what it's
about it's not a one-off he said this
this was something it's just something
that's normal so are you racist now is
this something that's that's coming out
if you support some like this can we
question are you really are you somebody
who's for equal rights for all are you
really for Humanity are you really a
hidden are you undercover racist yeah no
I think 100% is question yeah no it is I
think if you're if you're a Zionist at
this point you're a racist I think
that's that's a foregone oh there's no
doubt with you that's it no I think
that's it I think whether you admit it
or not that's a secondary issue but um
you know and I'll give people you know
benefit of the doubt who have been
indoctrinated like you said a lot of
people you know and and the government
of Israel has worked really hard to keep
that sort of hermetic seal on the
indoctrination you know they've got the
summer camps and they've got the
birthright tours and they've got all
these sorts of things that they just
like you said the Disney fairy tale that
they feed you about all of Israel is if
anybody hasn't watched it israelism was
a really nice documentary that what's it
called israelism that was developed by a
Jew also right yes it was these are Jews
putting it together we commend them
because exactly what you're saying I
heard someone say and I don't know if
it's an exaggeration but it it's telling
they said people everybody's a z every
Jew is a Zionist until they actually go
to Israel and or Palestine and they see
like the reality right and at that point
it's a moral choice that people have to
make and this is why Allah says in the
Quran it's not the eyes that are blind
but it's the hearts there are people who
have their hearts are awake and alive
and they see the reality and they're
like they become very disillusioned some
of them they they go and they hide and
they just go about their lives and they
just like wow it's like it's just
whatever but others take it even a step
further and found these organizations
such such as Jewish voice voice for
peace and other organizations and say
that no we are going to educate the
world we're going to show people what's
really going on um and we're going to
try to put a stop to it because they
realized that they had been
indoctrinated for their whole lives uh
my guest recently Sam Sami Hamdi yeah uh
he said had breakfast together this
morning yeah he said something very
interesting he said that look uh we
could sympathize for the beginning yes
what started Zionism yes and it wasn't
the persecution of Jews by Muslims it
was actual persecu by who by the Nazis
and Europe and the Christians and
historically Christians that's the only
thing if you want to go back a thousand
years if you want to go back a thousand
years there's no disrespect to the no
disrespect to anybody but let's be
honest if you're going to go down that
route yeah check your own uh under under
your own finger fingernails because the
history of Christianity and Christians
towards Jews in the last thousand years
is not pretty it is not pretty whether
you go to Russia and Eastern Europe
whether you go to Western Europe the
pgms the you know we language has
changed you know genocide is a fairly
recent term but um all these things that
they that they have names for that they
now weaponize in an unfair way such as
blood Lael and these sorts of things you
know this was systematic in Christian
history towards Jews right that the
dehumanization the the you know
animalistic language you know calling
them rats and and horri horrible things
but that's the history of Christianity
and well let's say Christians according
to Islam unacceptable unacceptable M I
want people to understand this I want
the Bachman and the Christian
conservatives and whoever is watching
you're actually a Muslim that's like a
priest that's like a pastor that's like
you know that's a community leader for
the Muslims yes so now you really did
your homework I mean to come and and
this is another fascinating thing you're
a former Christian who became an a
Muslim Imam that's really deep yeah yeah
so continue on yeah no I mean it's just
like this this is the history of
Christians towards Jews and the the Nazi
Holocaust against the Jews was simply
the last chapter of Jewish oppression in
Christian Europe the the the history is
deep and long so if you want to any
conservative wants to go back a thousand
years I will put the reputation of the
Muslims anywhere from Morocco to
Indonesia I compare that put it up
against the against the European
Christian treatment of Jews for the last
thousand years I will give you every
single Dollar in my bank account that I
have to my name I'll stake my reputation
on it I'll stake my life on it I will
challenge you
show me what Christians have done to
Jews in the last thousand years and show
me what Muslims have done to Jews in the
last thousand years and you will you
will have to face the facts that
Christianity and especially European
Christians have had a very checkered
history with the Jewish population the
Jewish community and the relationship
between Muslims and Jews has been much
more amicable and much more mutually
supportive when the Jews were pushed out
of because the Jews were pushed out of
uh of Andalusia of southern Spain uh
before the Muslims were when uh you know
they quote unquote unified Spain the
Jews were the first to be kicked out
forced conversion Spanish Inquisition
who sent ships on his own dime to go
save the Jews from Muslim Spain or
formerly Muslim Spain on their own dime
on their own dime it was the Ottoman
Sultan bazid II wow he sent ships I
believe you know it's this is in the
late 1400s so you know the numbers we
don't know exactly how many numbers but
somewhere between 150 to 300,000 Jews
were taken back saved rescued refugees
from Spain were taken to the Ottoman
Empire settled in Istanbul and they
actually now they there's still a strong
Jewish presence in estanbul to this day
there's actually organizations that I I
read a little bit about about this uh in
the last few weeks that um document the
history of the Jewish community in uh
turkey and in uh in Istanbul in
particular
and they say that yeah we were settled
here we were encouraged here and the
ottoman Sultan bayazid II blamed
Ferdinand and Isabella for their
shortsightedness he said you've enriched
me and impoverished yourself when
talking about how he came to to to save
and to welcome uh the Jewish Community
from Spain right the Muslims were then
the next to be kicked out so you know
you could go again I'll stake everything
I own on this compare European
Christians last years their behavior
towards Jews and Muslims Behavior
towards Jews I will I will stake
everything on it you will find that
European Christians had a hard time
dealing with Jews they had a lot of
animosity and hatred towards Jews the
whole Judean Christian Val
judeo-christian values is a very very
new thing it's a very very new idea if
you go back into the history the history
is ugly it's honestly it makes you sick
to see how the Jews have been treated in
Europe by Christians uh not by Muslims
not by Muslims by Christians and the
Nazi Holocaust was simply the last chap
in that story so you can totally
sympathize with the Jewish people when
it comes to uh the Raw Deal that they
got but unfortunately unfortunately that
was um misdirected that sort of
Oppression and the uh the horrors that
they that they endured was misdirected
and now it was taken out just like if
you have a bad day at work and then you
come and you take it out on your wife or
your kids they came and they took it out
on the Muslims and the Palestinians uh a
tab attempting to establish some sort of
imaginative you know nation state that's
just for them it's a racist State it's a
Jewish state right and you know it's
ironic because the United States
recently the Congress passed that sort
of I don't know technically the term
resolution or whatever uh Israel as a
Jewish State without realizing that
that's racist period to say that Israel
is a Jewish State and must be and has
the right to be a Jewish state in a land
that is populated by not just Jews but
also by Christians and Muslims right if
the role were reversed if the shoe was
on the other foot and there was a place
where let's say like like Kenya or let's
say like some place in Africa that has
like a a population that's significant
Muslim population but also significant
Jewish and Christian population and they
came out and they said that this is an
Islamic State and etc etc etc everybody
will be up in arms you'd see it on the
news 247 right we're just asking people
to be fair just be fair and don't lie be
historical about it the Thousand-Year
animosity is between Christians and Jews
not between Muslims and Jews so you gave
some example you had the um Spain Golden
Ages for Jews and I just had a rabbi on
recently he also confirmed this I mean
this is something that's just well-known
document through his history uh Jews
flourished the most at this time didn't
they of course you had France uh every
time the Christians were in charge of
the Holy Land we're talking about
Palestine Jews were kicked out and not
allowed to settle there say that again
so every time that Christians were in
charge of the Holy Land Jerusalem yes
Jerusalem Jews were kicked out and not
allowed to live there not by Muslims not
by Muslims the opposite when Muslims
were in charge they repopulated they
repopulated and Jews were allowed to
come and settle yeah this is a
historical fact you can go look it up
yeah like the the best thing for Judaism
has been Islam when it it talks about
the Jewish community and it's um it's a
it's it's well what do we want to say
It's ability to survive as a community
the best the best Ally that the Jews
have had historically have been the
Muslims yeah if you've had uh Islam save
the jury you've have David Warstein and
other academics I often always you know
quote this because it's very important
uh in Bosnia you had um so where my
family's from you had the uh BOS mus the
Muslims there hiding the Jews in the cab
you had Muslims here in Sao in Bosnia
that they were actually helping tell us
talk to about that history they were
helping to save the Jews going to the
extent of even putting them um in the
cab or in the Islamic dress is that yes
yes during the World War I the Muslims
and the bosnak people in Saro in the
whole the bosnan heroa are protecting
the Jews wearing the nikab especially
nikab Muslims would put this on the Jews
on this way the helping to kill to hide
the to hide hide his house so so the
Nazis wouldn't kill them yes yes yes yes
yes to protect the protect them the Jews
from the Nazis I don't know if you know
about that they were hiding them in
theab uh you had you mentioned turkey
France the forging of documents has
happened a lot uh so the Nazis couldn't
get them to pretend that like they were
Muslim giving them um from the mass you
know about this right so there's so many
countless examples and then uh so when
Michelle Bachman she's um pushing this
uh these lies out there this dangerous
stuff it's very dangerous it's just as
dangerous as genocide Joe telling
everybody that uh you know the
Palestinians killed babies beheaded
babies and then somebody comes and stabs
a six-year-old it's just as dangerous so
the Quran tells us I mean and we don't
have a problem would you agree now if
anything is confirmed because um you're
following the Quran verba word of God
Almighty where Allah the Creator God
Almighty in Arabic in AR is interesting
that uh Jesus would say allaha oh
interesting right so he say allaha in
Arabic Allah this the Creator Allah um
and now when you look at it and you see
that okay uh the Creator is telling us
that if an untrustworthy person comes to
us verify check it up news comes to you
don't just just accept it blindly go and
verify it so the sources for many of
these things are people who've been
exposed for lying yeah no definitely
it's it's it's you can't trust anything
that the IDF says at this point they've
been caught lying so many times and I
think I believe Christopher Hitchens has
like a nice write up on who who has done
journalistic work there and about
how the the amount and the audacity of
the lies actually like takes you a back
right it's actually surprising like most
people would feel shame to lie so
frequently about and so systematically
about such big things even if okay like
whatever whatever side quote unquote
that you support just think in in a in a
context of War do you believe what the
governments are going to put out about
themselves everybody knows that in in
the context of War they call it the fog
of War this is all propaganda but
atrocity propaganda atrocity propaganda
right and so we've we've seen that you
know many people have marked that CNN
and MSNBC and Fox news they've become
stenographers they they for for the IDF
they literally just whatever their
handed they pass it off as if it's fact
and that's not journalism in fact in
fact one of the things that we've seen
and this is another thing where the
average American person understands that
are we do not have a free press that we
say Legally Legally the Protections in
the Bill of Rights that we have a free
press but de facto the reality on the
ground is that our Legacy Media our main
mream media is occupied territory by
major corporations that are influenced
by Foreign Nations and we do not
actually have a free press the closest
thing that we have to Free Press is the
information that's AA able to be like
shared freely on on Twitter and social
media uh which is why the people who are
younger who get their knows who get
their news from Twitter and social media
have a very very different take on
things than people who are relying on
traditional mass media right so you know
we have to listen it's like people don't
understand and people are going to try
again and I say this and everybody has
to pay attention to this and be aware of
this people are going to try to paint
you and me as Traders people are going
to try to paint you and me as
anti-American it's going to be the
McCarthy era all over again they're
going to paint us as terrorist
supporters or terrorist sympathizers or
whatever we care about the United States
of America and we care about it doing
the right thing we want Redemption we do
not want to see the United States
government or the politicians or the
media in in the pocket of a foreign
country that is something that every
American can agree to except for
probably a handful of of cynical people
that we want the free flow of
information we don't want wartime
propaganda from one side we don't want
to be lied to we don't want our
government to be lied to or our
politicians be handed propaganda from a
foreign nation and get up and announce
it as if it's fact yeah this is
absolutely ridiculous it's unexcusable
and any society that's based on such
lies is destined to fall and I don't
want it to fall I want it to I want it
to improve right I think tar Taro Carl
tuckerson you heard him yeah I think
he'd agree with you I think he was
speaking almost identical yeah that he's
seeing you know all these issues that
are happening at home we sending all
this money and putting these other
things ahead of yeah of course uh home
base right but people will try to put
you and me in jail for uh supporting
terrorism because we're Muslims whereas
Tucker Carlson's safe mhm and so you
know America has to to reconcile with
that as well why people are going to
weaponize and attempt to use these
things in order to silence critics and
to silence critique and they have to
reconcile themselves to the fact that
when you critique your own country and
your own Homeland it's because we want
it to be better it's because we actually
care that if we didn't care about it if
we didn't want it to be better we would
just be silent about this but we're
raising our heads and we're putting
ourselves at risk because we don't think
that it should go on this way we we need
to do better we have to do better and
the longevity of this country depends on
it doing better uh so some of these um
these things these
grotesque things that I put out there I
I I was um looking at some uh
investigated journalists you have uh I
don't know if you heard of The gry Zone
yeah and other independent journalists
um they were uncovering that some of
these relief organizations are coming
from disaster relief groups that are
fighting for media attention and
charitable donations these groups are in
the business bus of raising money and
right now atrocity fundraising is a gold
rush very wealthy and very emotional
Jewish westerners are opening up their
wallets to organizations and Charities
and these organizations are jockeying
for position as the best charity to give
money to and nothing raises money like a
good story for example Eli beer the
president of United hatzalah went on a
media tour around the United States
telling audiences that babies were
placed in ovens and baked to yes a
little baby in an oven they put him in
these bastards put these babies in an
oven and put on the oven we found the
kid a few hours later this propelled him
and his organization to the Forefront of
the media for several days earning tons
of awareness for his organization's work
he was able to leverage this media
attention into several fundraisers where
he managed to collect a whopping $50
million isra reporter isay Cohen
investigated and determined that the
story wasn't true another Israeli
journalist K lenon said had this to say
about Eli beer and the [__] of in
story like any good Jew who sees the
rich he thought about the money and told
a story that does not exist they were
repeating some of these um some of these
things that were debunked um with the
babies in ovens and and the mutilating
their bodies and some really just
disgusting thing that obviously if it's
true if it's true we condemn it 100% but
we're not going to believe the IDF when
they say that these things happen uh-huh
so this uh so this is something that
obviously is um something that Islam
condemns we would condemn but what was
interesting is that these relief
organization I don't if they classified
relief organizations these people were
repeating this and they were uh
repeating this atrocity propaganda and
what was happening the more they were
repeating it the more money was coming
in so they uncovered that at the end it
was debunked but they made 49 million
there you go follow the money follow the
money 49 million there's there's money
to be made in the the weapons industry
which is why people and this is
something that President Eisenhower when
he was leaving office in the in the 50s
I believe he warned the United States
about the military industrial complex um
you know uh the there's money to be made
in weapons there's money to be made in
tragedy there's money to be made in
these ludicrous claims right but at the
end of the day the truth has to Prevail
we have to speak the truth and the
people that are trying to stop us from
speaking the truth they want to keep the
money train coming they just want to
keep on lining their pockets and making
money off of these things okay uh last
uh video here it's by the same former
congresswoman and I want to get your
interpretation of this it's time that
Gaza ends the 2 million people who live
there they are clever assassins they
need to be removed from that land that
land needs to be turned into a national
park politicians like that I don't how
would you interpret that I don't believe
that politicians like that actually
believe that I I believe that they don't
have any values that they're just snakes
that try to play to an audience and whip
up a crowd but how can she be she's a
Dean at a
Christian um I think Christian uh
University listen one of the things that
pushed me to Islam I think it was in
2006 uh and there was escalation in
Palestine around that time and in the
church that I used to go to the pastor
gave a sermon about why we have to
support Israel against the
Palestinians and I asked her after you
know I went up to her I said how could
you possibly say that I don't like this
doesn't make any sense and she said to
me well the Jews believe in the same God
that we do and Muslims don't now that's
someone with a master's degree from a
Divinity School and I was a teenager and
I knew that this person has no idea what
they're talking about so you can have
all your Pomp and Circumstance you can
have all your degrees you can have all
your institutions it doesn't reflect
quality it doesn't reflect truth right
and actually there's an entire system of
this fluff that passes a scholarship
that passes as you know as rigor that in
reality it's just a castle made of sand
I think it's very important uh that
Christians really look into this a
little further with this con man who um
and I had a pastor and I think we
touched upon this last time but I think
it's so important this con man uh Cyrus
scoffield who learned from someone who
knew John Nelson Derby he got all these
fringed teachings from Christianity it
got supported by the Zionist
organization they printed this in Oxford
printing press they pushed this Cyro
cyosc field reference Bible into into I
think million copies for free and then
this is what is the modern modern day
now uh with the um interpretation of
certain verses connecting it to Israel
like uh this is the bread and butter uh
whoever blesses thee is blessed whoever
curs the is curs the modern day Israel
with classical Old Testament Israel that
the Jews have to be in Israel for the
second coming of Jesus the Rapture 1,00
years of Christianity had nothing to say
about this is all false yeah this is all
this this fake uh prophecy pushing uh is
something that's not really part of uh
authentic uh whatever you have of the
true teachings of Christianity this is
uh yeah false and that's an important
part uh Point why religious literacy is
important some people they make the
mistake and they say oh you religious
guys you know you guys are all
responsible for violence and stuff like
that and it's actually the opposite if
you don't have good religious
scholarship look at what comes about
Christians yeah so they they don't feel
guilty not supporting this this has
nothing to do with their religion
actually they check this up you just
need to actually follow your faith and
not follow the modern ideologies that
pretend to be representatives of your
faith uh last question before we
conclude um why did you what did it for
you that you find that you actually uh
accepted Islam there's a common push out
there now within conservatives and and
uh I commend them for that have more
kids family and that uh because they
feel like okay Muslims are having more
kids and they think that's why Islam is
growing but you're you're an example of
Islam is growing because people have
investigated we're sincerely looking for
the truth and asked the creator of the
heavens and earth God Almighty to guide
them and you're one of those what did it
for you yeah definitely I mean two
things I think one that's like
methodological is that I just always I
investigate you know I don't take people
for their word uh if it comes to we're
talking nation states or anybody else I
I read and I study I try to understand
right um so if somebody is going to come
to me and tell me that the two two
million people Ina are all assassins or
mercenaries I'm going to go investigate
that I'm not going to believe that right
because I'm not stupid right I know that
people lie and people have agendas and
people are paid by people Etc and then
the second thing once I went through the
process of sort of investigating about
Islam I found that Islam was the only
religion Faith system whatever you want
to call it that had guidance for every
aspect of human life that um it had
guidance for you know how to use the
bathroom how to structure an economy how
to conduct a business contract how to
treat your family uh how to leave your
inheritance behind right things that
honestly Christianity doesn't have right
Christianity has a lot of things that
has to do with um being a good person
treating people right and these sorts of
you know personal qualities but it
doesn't have much of a vision for
society and it doesn't have and and
historically that's not what the
disciples were concerned with they were
in oppressed minority they were getting
slaughtered by the Romans right they
weren't thinking about how to build and
how to govern right right um so that's
why there's there's basically nothing
there in Christianity to instruct you
how to govern and then you know other
sort of non-religious ideologies you
know they talk a lot about politics and
and economy and things like that but
they don't they're not going to make you
into a better person they're not going
to make you into a more generous person
a more honorable person a more virtuous
person a Kinder person um and Islam is
the only uh Faith system whatever you
want to say that combines both it will
both guide you how you should structure
your individual life your family life
your community your Society your economy
everything beautiful a complete system
way of life yeah and all B all all built
on the worship of how many gods just one
just one can that be three in one or one
and three five and three just no no no
fancy mathematics or when you say one
that's it we actually mean one pure
monotheism not one real one pure
monotheism beautiful thank you so much
Eddie always pleasure may Allah bless
you you
too if you're like me you've been
watching the dean show for now almost 20
years Allah preserve our man Eddie and
continue his work he is Allah has opened
for him a new door we went from the dean
show to the dean Center which is going
to be in Florida and I've been rooting
for this project I support it I urge you
to support it too we know this uh
brother in his work he's got a track
record that speaks for itself this
Center is going to be successful
inshallah as successful as the show is
and all his other daa works go to the
website support it and we look forward
to seeing more good news coming out of
[Music]
there I cannot leave without giving you
a gift if you're not yet Muslim and you
tune in to see what these Muslims are
talking about and you like a free copy
of the Quran go ahead and visit theen
show.com we'll take care of the postage
and everything and get it delivered to
you and if you still have some questions
about Islam call us at 1800 662
4752 we'll see you next time until then
peace be with you assalam alaykum